welcome back to cbs mornings here at 7
30. we are live from the ukraine poland
border crossing where the scenes of
desperation still unfolding behind me
could not be stopped by many months of
diplomacy the question is will sanctions
help new financial sanctions targeting
russians billionaire oligarchs will be
discussed by european officials later
today that's according to the reuters
news agency of course russian-owned
luxury yachts and jets and property are
already targets of several western
nations including the u.s britain has
sanctioned a dozen of russia's
billionaires so far sanction them
directly and its parliament is now
considering new laws that would make it
harder for those oligarchs to spend
their money there mts thai app is in
london with that story
mts people are looking for anything to
stop this good morning
yeah you're absolutely right tony good
morning well this economic crime bill is
really aimed at preventing wealthy
russians from either hiding or
laundering their money here in the uk
but the concern is that it's really too
little too late
london has long been a playground for
the wildly rich thank you mr speaker
prime minister boris johnson says the
days of dirty money are over it means
oligarchs in london will have nowhere to
hide oligarchs russian industry titans
with ties like tentacles to the kremlin
are being targeted in tough new economic
sanctions by uk lawmakers we will
continue working through our hit list of
oligarchs focusing on their houses their
yachts and every aspect of their lives
but that hit list doesn't include
britain's most famous oligarch roman
abramovich who's known president putin
for decades worth an estimated 12
billion dollars he owns the london
soccer club chelsea just last week
abramovic put the club up for sale with
the reported 2.5 billion dollar price
tag promising to donate proceeds to
victims of the war in ukraine
but it's improperty where most oligarchs
store their cash the uk has laundered
the world's dirty money for decades
rachel davies is with the
anti-corruption watchdog transparency
international
we've found 1.5 billion pounds worth of
uk property that's owned by russians who
are either connected to corruption or
have close ties to the kremlin now this
is almost certainly just the tip of the
iceberg this is britain's second largest
home second only to buckingham palace
valued at over 400 million dollars it's
been linked to billionaire andre guryev
a new yorker magazine investigation
found it was purchased by a shell
company in the british virgin islands
was in a meeting with putin just days
after russia invaded ukraine mikhail
friedman who owns this multi-million
dollar london mansion has already been
sanctioned the russian oligarch warns
sanctions won't stop
imposing sanctions against us here
just create an enormous pressure for us
personally but we do not have any impact
for political decision
at all this will be about hurting putin
still the economic crime bill which
closes loopholes like the use of shell
companies as a way to launder cash is
designed to put more pressure on those
with close ties to vladimir putin and
those who make it easy for them here in
london we have an army of professionals
lawyers bankers accountants estate
agents many of them are acting with
integrity but unfortunately a lot of
them are either willfully engaging with
corrupt individuals or turning a blind
eye
while they help them launder their money
now as the war in ukraine continues to
sort of rage on this battle to find and
freeze russian assets is really just
getting started but here's the thing
even with these new laws the concern is
is that russian oligarchs will still
find ways to shield their assets
from scrutiny tony
mts tayyip for us in london mts thank
you very much appreciate